[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so I'm going to
take you in the gym and we'll be doing
my favorite fat burning team circuit
training there will be three separate
stations strength cardio and core so for
each station we will be doing five
different exercises in five minutes and
we want to repeat all the stations twice
so the total workout time will be about
a forty minutes let's start on the
strength station and work on our total
body
the first exercise will be lunge and
twist so this workout works on the legs
hips and the twisting motion will work
on your core and obliques so grab a ball
or a kettlebell that weighs between four
to eight kilos if you're an absolute
beginner you can perform this workout
without any weight as you lunge forward
or with check that both legs are hip
width apart and point it forward as you
lower yourself your legs should be at a
90 degree angle then engage your core
extend your arms forward and twist to
the opposite side so we want to perform
each workout for 50 seconds with a quick
10 seconds transition in between the
next workout will be burpees press up
which works more on your upper body
chest and showed it again you can use a
ball or a capybara with between four to
eight kilos start standing tall as you
lower yourself place the weight on the
floor jump both legs back and lower
yourself into a push-up position
then jump back in and as you rise up to
stand press the weight overhead repeat
as many reps as you can in 50 seconds
when you're in a push-up position always
make sure that your back is flat and
core engaged as depress the with
overhead avoid arching your lower back
now let's bring our heart rate back up
the third workout is stepper squat jump
you can also do this workout using a big
box squats and hop on to the stepper and
hop back down when you land it is very
important to keep your knees soft and
land in a squat position
so never lock your knees
or land extending this word God will
really push your hunter it up and you
will really feel the burn in your size
and come this next workout is really fun
ball slams this will develop power
strength speed and coordination grab a
wicked med ball and stand in a white
stump
bring the ball overhead contract your
abs bend your knees and drag the chest
down to slam the ball into the ground
with as much force as possible retrieve
the ball as it bounces up and
immediately go into your neck strap
perform this exercise with maximum
effort and remember to keep your knees
bent push your butt back as you slam the
ball this exercise works the entire body
and it burns crazy amounts of calories
for the final workout in the strength
station let's work on our back muscles
back row you can do this workout with a
barbell a pair of dumbbells or fitness
bag just like what I have here so stand
sugar with the pot keep your knees soft
and bend forward at your hips until your
total is nearly parallel to the floor
pull the fitness bag or barbell up to
with your belly keep your elbows pointed
back chest up and back slaps squeeze
your back muscles for a second or two
right at the top and lower yourself to
starting position
perform as many repetitions as you can
within one minute rest you're done with
the strength station that was five
minutes long now take a one-minute break
breathe keep yourself hydrated and we
want to move on to the cardio station
let's hit the treadmill for the next
five minutes if you were to go for a
low-impact workout you can also choose
to use a bike cross trainer or even
stepper in order to maximize fat burn we
want to play around with the speed so on
the first third and final minute I want
you to sprint as fast as you can between
11 and 13 kilometers per hour remember
to pace a breathing to help you run
faster and longer
feel the burn feel your heart rate
pumping and stay strong so between the
second and fourth minutes I want you to
bring the spit down to either a slow jog
or walk and recover take this minute to
really catch your breath breathe deeply
and bring your heart rate down slightly
if you struggle remember to focus on
your goal and run with your heart okay
well done that was five minutes of speed
interval training on the cardio station
now take a one-minute break and we want
to move on to the final station core the
first exercise will be full extension to
work on your upper and lower abs you can
use a weighted ball
dumbbells plates or kettlebell hold the
ball with both hands and lie on your
back with your arms extended overhead
and legs straight out as you breathe out
go up and bring your knees to your chest
and your arms towards your legs keep
your core tight and slowly return to
starting position avoid arching your
lower back your legs should only go down
as far as you can while keeping your
back flat again we want to do as many
repetitions as we can in 50 seconds
without sacrificing to perform next my
favourite core workout by the man plank
to challenge yourself place both hands
on the ball and perform the exercise
keep your back flat and bring one knee
towards your elbow really engage your
core to keep your balance if this is too
tough for you then do without the ball
and keep your palms on the mat this is a
great core workout and you will also
feel it in your arms and showed it the
third exercise is Russian twist which
works on the entire core and also
obliques so hold a ball cut the bell or
dumbbells directly in front of you sit
on the mat with your knees bent and feet
flat on the floor then keeping the spine
long lean back slightly until you feel
your core engaged beginners you can
place both feet on the floor to
challenge yourself lift both legs a few
inches of the floor and keep twisting
perform this exercise in a smooth
continuous motion so don't let the
weight rest on the floor
let's lie on your back and perform
flutter kicks this is a killer workout
for your lower abs you can place both
hands it's just by your ears and lift
your shoulders few inches of the floor
without tensing your neck lift both feet
off the ground and move your legs in a
fluttering up and down motion keep the
movement small to really work on your
lower abs beginners you can rest your
head on the mat and take your arms by
your sides
choose under your butt to support your
lower back keep your abs constantly
contracted throughout the exercise so
going for your breath okay breathe as
you move your legs now let's bring our
heart rate back up as we enter the
course station let's hit it with
mountain climber start in a high plank
position with the hands slightly wider
they should width apart and get your
core and drive your knee up to with your
chest one at a time while maintaining
your body as straight as possible keep
the movement as far as you can and bring
your heart rate up to challenge yourself
even more but if your arms on a ball it
is not easy but this is a great
progression to really improve on your
balance keep pushing yourself
don't stop now because this is the final
workout and rest relax wind down and get
into a child's pose breathe and just
bring your heart rate down take between
one to two minutes break and we want to
repeat all three stations for another
round this is my favorite jeans circuit
training which I like to do twice weekly
it combines strength cardio and of the
core so the goal is to take short breaks
to constantly keep your heart rate
elevated and as a result you'll be
burning a lot more calories as you
progress you can also mix and measure
the workouts so the next time you hit
the gym try this to give this video a
thumbs up share it and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more new
videos every week you also turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new
video all the best